this video contains a lot of screaming
and a lot of spoilers beware I'm sick of
you and your [ __ ] and you're not
gonna stay away from me getting in my
room I don't know okay I regret this
sorry
I mean you're just cuz you have a penis
flopping around doesn't mean I'm staying
are you alright my bread here oh I get
it now it makes sense
haha oh you're angry now aren't you
i play Yahtzee with those why me what
did i do what did i do seriously what
did i do I never [ __ ] with anyone oh
you're too fat ha ha ha
fatty fatty fat fat or what's the matter
oh oh just kidding it's gotta be quiet
it's not here is it better
spring bell I hate the hiding I hate it
or you may think I'm in the locker as a
wise man once said don't wear tampons if
you're a boy well [ __ ] there's a kitchen
oh you idiot watch get up man get off me
ugly [ __ ] home
whoa jump high da da da da da da
alright what have we got here
oh no it has a little scratching stop
talking to me toilet I'm shut up what
hey default internet twist it's a toilet
he talked to me he talked to me they
talk to me hey god damn what did I do
you is fabulous
yeah that's why I keep touching yourself
this is some [ __ ] nice porno I did
not cheat on your girlfriend cheap
cheated no as it may I'm don't take on
this I'm a Big Mac oh hey are you going
Oh JA naughty hem the bet that plant you
scared the [ __ ] out of me hope you guys
enjoyed this montage if you did go ahead
and leave a like it helps me out a lot
if you want to check out the entire
outlet series go ahead and click here if
you want to watch more montages like
hair and if you want to become a bro
today and seriously you're not a bro yet
go ahead as a sky I'll see you in the
next video bros stay awesome
but first must confidential ah not
anymore
not anymore